in this series and we surprise you on
the strip away we the complexity and
hard craft and teach you how to cook
amazing food standing on your head that
is amazing
incredibly tender from the kitchen
novice to the budding chef I'm gonna
give you the confidence that recipes and
the insider knowledge to make you a much
better cook slice around wasting nothing
I made my name cooking some of the
world's most demanding kitchens in my
restaurants I expect perfection every
play has to be worthy of a Michelin star
and every time you may go now I will
show you some simple and accessible
recipes or fantastic food that you can
cook easily at home and Co I'll be
holding you by the hand just gettin
better and better and better teaching
you everything from how to cook on a
budget to bake in real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cooking course we'll ever need
welcome to my optimum cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
let the dish slow cook is a brilliant
way of getting maximum flavor with
minimal effort my first recipe melts in
the mouth and because the oven does most
of the work is a cinch to make
slow-cooked fiery lamb cooking is all
about being bold and adventurous and
this dish is exciting because it's
slowly cooked and the longer it cooks
the more flavor so it becomes marinade
my lamb first Cheers
we're gonna use a mixture of red and
green take off the tops and just slice
in garlic
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just get it in there cooking up to
three hours everything's got a blends
and almost sort of cures itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilies two teaspoons in a
touch of dried oregano some little cumin
seeds the blend and the fragrance so
they give out is extraordinary they
release a little oil as well helps to
tenderize the lamb touch of salt pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamp olive
oil just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinate for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when I'm
tuck-in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced secret
slicing vegetables for braising is not
getting too thin you slice the onions
too thin they burn you've got that
horrible char taste on that slow braised
braising it's just a chef term that
means cooking and liquid on a low heat
making the meat incredibly moist and
beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan get that nice and hot just a
touch of olive oil lamb in hold the bone
you in control then into the pan
on that white fats to start rendering so
it'll add more fat therefore making it a
lot more flavor some as it braises
chilies cinnamon in mix that up and
don't be scared you're not burning this
you're sort of searing the lamb shanks
and this is the important part right at
the very beginning we're gonna color on
the lamb which washes off as it braises
in the oven so be generous with that
color
vegetables in well and then cut the
Bailey's so now you lift the lamb up and
get the lamb fat on top of the
vegetables now blaze the pan with red
wine the glazing means that you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lift it up into that
sauce it can really transform that dish
always it lays then bring to the boil
and cook for about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now that
the stock bring that stock back up to
the ball and then into the oven now
don't cover it when you cover it all the
conversation comes off the lid your lamb
becomes gray all this effort that
exciting spice gets washed away no lid
and in the oven for hours a slow cook on
a low heat of 160 degrees gives us
Pisces time to work and transform the
meat so it's mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those out on to a plate you can
just see that meat sliding down juicy
and incredibly tender grab it by the
shank rolling around that rich
Alysha sauce sauce nice beautiful just
get some mint don't chop it just pick
that fresh mint and let it snow and
there you go a very spicy delicious
melting or a mouth lamb shank amazing
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pesto's
to dressings and custom around 15 quid
used to grind spices and your max out on
flavor
get perfect textures and always be
totally in control make sure you got a
nice large circumference of the bowl
take and grind away the heavier the more
durable they are the more confidence it
gives you when you're pounding and
there's almost a way of confirming
homemade hand-pounded grab yourself a
pestle and water and soon you'll be
spicing with ease
spices are brilliant way to add an extra
layer and a depth of complexity to any
dish learning to use them properly will
really improve your couple here are
three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
first up a very easy chili and spice
whitebait
[Music]
start with the spice coating toast
Szechuan peppercorns and coriander seeds
in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
[Music]
add chilli flakes and grind a pestle and
mortar to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour seasoned and
mix add olive oil to a hot pan coat
white bait in the spicy flour mix then
fry
whitebait are annoyingly fish they're
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spice whitebait an easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus start with my take
on razzle her newt a classic Moroccan
spice blend in a dry pan toast cinnamon
cloves coriander fenugreek and fennel
seeds then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready add paprika and grind into a fine
powder for the hummus peel and chop
flutter nut squash put on a baking tray
and add garlic simply bashed and chopped
ginger drizzle with olive oil seasoned
and sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour inches soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
at tahini a nutty pace made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
Flitz into a luxuriously creamy and
textured spice is toasted for maximum
flavor amazing roasted squash hummus my
final deliciously spicy dishes curry
spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first the fragrant curry paste roast
coriander and cumin seeds into a para
mattock
then grind having crushed garlic chilli
powder turmeric and finely chopped
ginger
[Music]
bring together with olive oil to form a
thick paste for the soup by finely
chopped onions in olive oil
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cube potatoes chicken stock and
season
when the potato has softened stirring
creamed corn
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices and transfer to a
blender and blitz until smooth
for texture add more whole sweetcorn
hate and it's ready to serve
[Music]
wonderfully satisfying curried spiced
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch three more stunning
recipes that make cooking with spice
simple
[Music]
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices when I buy my spice I only want
the best and it always pays to get
expert advice Burgert Aerith has been
selling every spice Under the Sun in
London's Notting Hill for over 20 years
so she already knows what she's talking
about
I love supposed to smell the texture
color spaces are so versatile something
very very simple can be really
transformed into something really
delicious with thousands of aromatic
ingredients on a shelves if it smells
good she sells it if you buy spices buy
them whole then you can try roast and
crime demand you need them and then they
will release the essential oils whole
spices you can keep for years give them
a good bashing and bottle with your
rolling pin or whatever and you see
there was still a Roma and you can taste
it you smell it then it's fine there's
four main spices one is sweet one is
sour one is bitter and one is hot this
is cinnamon and that is really a great
example of a sweet spice when you buy
cinnamon cool like this you have to
check that you have loads of different
layers in here then you can either crime
this or you'd break a piece off I mean
this doesn't smell of anything now but
if you revel it in your hand just
quickly like this and then you smell it
again this is just unbelievable if you
have spaghetti bolognaise put a pinch of
cinnamon in it to bring out the flavor
so monk this is one of those really
special spices sour like a lemon but it
has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't left unless you tried it a great
example for a bit of spice would
actually be turmeric this is actually a
root be closed in the ground like ginger
use it very very sparingly about that
much will actually color you a curry or
rice dish wonderful yellow watch your
fingers you get really yellow fingers
from it and then we come to the hot
spices one spice that I could
and that is Hungarian paprika paprika is
the powdery form of a bell pepper what
makes the Hungarian paprika different is
that they actually Croton vineyards it's
sort of between the mines
it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have a ever
Birgit spot-on about the power of spices
to transform dishes whether savory or
sweet here's my quick guide to the
spices are used most black pepper this
is the spice I couldn't do without
always buy a whole and grind yourself so
you get the freshest flavor cardamom
these pods come in green or black types
and have a fantastic spicy sweet taste
brilliant for everything from curries to
rice dishes and puddings coriander these
citrusy seeds are perfect hole in
pickles or grind to use in fragrant
stews and soups cumin a savory spice
that's pungent and nutty it's great in
marinades with delicious meat and fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes and nutmeg warm
and spicy is delicious and a bechamel
sauce finally saffron these sweet
strands infuse a brilliant bright red
color and are great in risottos and even
though it's more expensive than gold at
pinch goes a long long way store your
spices properly and they'll last for
years you keep it airtight in a tin or
in a glass jar in your cupboard don't be
scared of spices like an aftershave or a
perfume you have to select it yourself
it has to fit in with your taste and
with your kitchen supermarkets and good
local shops sell an amazing array of
different spices so there's no excuse
for not being adventurous be bold find
what you like and spice up your cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes and giving
them a new twist to make the modern and
vibrant
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of life
fragrant spice rice pudding I love
cooking with spices but you don't have
to just cook savory dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level
[Music]
first off spices this is a fresh vanilla
pot fragrant and packed full of flavor
use the back of the knife and flatten it
that removes all those little seeds off
the skin of the vanilla pod take your
knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up smell is
incredible take the tip of the knife and
you scrape inside and look all those
seeds dying to come out that is
incredible
there are thousands of seeds still
ingrained to the pod so put them in to
the casserole
cardamon powerful spicy take two little
pods place your knife on top lightly
crack them cracking the cardamom pods
helps release all the amazing flavor
close because that kind of aniseed
flavor with a lot of depth one two three
cinnamon stick snap and in just smelling
that level of fragrance you can imagine
what the rice put into the taste-off
turn on the heat lightly toast those
spices just a couple of seconds
what's gonna happen it's just gonna sort
of enhance those spices in a way that it
just draws out an even more powerful
fragrance coconut milk in sugar two
tablespoons
milk
and then I cover tablespoons of cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice puddin
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious and so
comforting take a lime in the lime just
cuts through the richness of the coconut
it gives it that nice little bit of
acidity goes fantastically well with a
cinnamon and that fresh vanilla dice
have a taste hmm now let's go up to the
ball give it a nice little clean around
the outside and in with the rice use 200
grams of pudding rice don't wash it
beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven and
just turn that down to a light simmer
and the pudding rice starts to open up
and it absorbs all that coconut vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes balling it rapidly the rice
opens up and it goes into mush I want to
keep that nice texture that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury I will show you how
I take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what I do take two egg
yolks
separate them now give that a really
nice whisk to nice tablespoons of
mascarpone cheese whisk that into the
egg yolks just as nice and smooth it's
almost like finishing the rice pudding
and the delicious custard turn off the
gas add that into the rice pudding and
what happens it starts to enrich and
really thicken this rice pudding and
takes it to a completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up but look it's like rich
aromatic lava bubbling away finally
great more citrus zest the lime on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
the rice pudding is phenomenal then put
it in the oven 15 minutes at 200 degrees
to finish cooking the rice and develop
the intensive aromatic flavors
look at that an incredibly fragrant rice
pudding how beautiful is that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and then
kitchen tips
at first how to zest a lemon the
important part is not to zest any the
pith watch the following technique and
I'll show you how with all these
original graters really important when
we use this lose the define zester not
the big rough one not the one for
slicing and not the other one for
grating this little one here onto a
plate because it's always easier to lift
off from the plate the needs of the
board and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes but
twisting the lemon round every time we
go down we twist same with the orange
and same with a line little tap if you
go too far let me just show you know you
got that white bitter pith that destroys
the wonderful zesty flavor and look
that's what we're looking for there it's
really nice vibrant lemon zest
garlic is a key ingredient can so many
spicy dishes my tip for finely chopping
am incent is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
but getting the most out root ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
[Music]
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge when grinding up spices if you
have any leftover you can store in an
airtight jar for up to two months great
for a spicy kick to have at your
fingertips
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking
you